I'm happy to to introduce this panel
today it is on education and government
and education is a is a very important
topic
you know I say that how many I mean if I
just asked this question how many people
in here I've ever heard anyone say I
want to move to Detroit so I can send my
kid to Detroit Public Schools right but
you can say our Baltimore public schools
the Philadelphia public schools or
Chicago Public Schools so that tells you
it's not a Detroit Public School problem
it's a system problem and so we have
three panelists here who are experts in
this field and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do it a little bit
different than Tim I'm going to
introduce them one at a time and each of
them will have 20 minutes to speak and
then we'll have time for questions
our first speaker speaking on the
problem with common core is joi pullman
she's the managing editor of the
Federalist and author of education the
education invasion while Common Core
fights parents for control of American
kids she's also an education research
fellow at the Heartland Institute and a
founding member of the Redeemer
Classical School most importantly she's
a graduate of Hillsdale College honors
and journalism program and she got an A
in my class if she remembers sin in 2008
she and her husband live in in the
Midwest and have five children aged
seven and younger and so if you could
help me introduce joy Pullman
[Applause]
before I begin I'd like to thank
Hillsdale for giving me a platform to
share some of the returns on their
investment in my life and the givers who
helped make mine my husband's education
at Hillsdale possible it's an honor to
be here and I've done my utmost to make
your attention today worthwhile
so to begin Common Core is only the
latest of many failed education ideas
that spend a lot of money and waste a
lot of people's time without measurably
benefiting Americans u.s. education has
been a morass of ineffective feds fad
since at least the 1950s an American
children generally received at best a
mediocre education even in the schools
we think of as the best in our country
the title of a 2010 education policy
book from Harvard University Press sums
up the last century and not favorably it
said it's titled the same thing over and
over our inability to improve American
education is at root a spiritual and
philosophical problem that stems from
ideas that have been proven false but
many Americans for myriad reasons
believe them Americans used to have a
cultural consensus about what children
should learn and for what purpose and
that kind of consensus was key to the
kind of coherent curriculum that is most
effective but the slow progressive a
progressive ization of our culture has
attacked that consensus and may have
destroyed it this has made restoring
good education to broader American
society if not nearly impossible then
deeply difficult this is quite simply a
disaster for our society even if you and
your children are well educated your
fellow citizens Mal education will hurt
you children subjected to a fragmented
and politicized curriculum learn less
and therefore govern themselves and
after adulthood their fellow Americans
poorly they failed to achieve their
potential which exacerbates the troubles
of an American economy suffocated by
government debt and social welfare
especially low-income children who are
now the majority of those attending US
public school
who are not lifted through a systemic
core curriculum are at risk for
consuming more public resources than
they contribute through higher dropout
rates lower workforce participation
lower family formation and higher
welfare consumption all children who are
not enculturated through a coherent
curriculum into our uniquely American
social ideals such as equality before
the law respect for free speech and
religious exercise and the duties of
self-government rather than the flaccid
character conducive to serfdom are a
threat to our exceptional culture and
system of government that has made the
United States the best exemplar of
freedom and human rights the world has
ever known so here I will discuss three
of common core's fatal flaws that make
it devastating to the American Way of
life first its focused on workforce
training instead of education for
citizenship second its expansion of
central planning and third its reliance
upon the administrative state which
strangles the consent of the governed
and individual rights such as
self-government and freedom of
association to the American founders
public education zki purpose was to
nourish a vibrant culture and morality
necessary for the system of government
they created and it's corresponding way
of life religion morality and knowledge
being necessary to good government and
the happiness of mankind schools and the
means of education shall be forever
encouraged says the 1987 Northwest
Ordinance one of the United States for
organic laws that help create the
country yet this is no longer the
purpose of American public education
Common Core the current ruling regime of
US public education and it's symbolic
epitome defines the purpose of Education
mainly in terms entirely unlike those of
the American founders this set of
curriculum and testing mandates claims
to provide a set of expectations for
student knowledge and skills that high
school graduates need to master to
succeed in college and careers in its
492 pages Common Core cites the words
college and career 82 times about once
every six pages yet not once does it
mention self-government civic
participation perception
truth or any higher purpose for becoming
an educated human being
besides self-centered economic
advancement common core reflects the
widespread belief that one goes to
school to get a job what the point of
that is nobody says it's just considered
an end in itself but work and money are
means not ends of course a good work
ethic is a virtue but not if it's
applied towards executing bank robberies
one can do a great good with a great
amount of money but not if one uses it
as Bill Gates did to fund a takeover um
of American education that degrades the
people's right to govern themselves and
occupies teacher and student time on
untried education theories dreamed up by
people who never taught in a k-12
classroom money is just a means and so
is economic growth what we must know
beyond how to employ these means is to
what end what does it profit a nation to
artificially encounter productively
expand its economy by dividing
households through easy divorce laws and
pressuring mothers to separate early
from their children or never to have
children at all with messages that a
nine to five is more socially valuable
what does it profit us to increase tax
revenues through supply-side mechanisms
so politicians are free or to create new
entitlement programs that will never
cease to enervate the American character
to gain the whole world but lose our
souls American politicians have for
decades not considered education a
crucial component of cultivating the
next generation to manage their own
affairs through the practical and moral
virtues this is the cultural mandate for
education policy at the heart of the
founders vision for an exceptional
United States of America instead
American politicians have seen an
economic mandate for education policy as
a mechanism to increase their power over
their fellow citizens by increasing the
tax revenue and programs at their
disposal common core reflects this
narrow selfish view of public education
and like the American founders I reject
it here's why
the Nobel prize-winning economist Milton
Friedman in a seminal 1955 essay
proposing k12 vouchers distinct
distinguished between two types of
education one he said was appropriate to
require taxpayers to fund and another
that was not the first kind was
education for citizenship for a stable
and democratic society he said is
impossible without widespread acceptance
of some common set of values and without
a minimum degree of literacy and
knowledge on the part of most citizens
the second kind was vocationally
oriented education for which an
individual's not taxpayers at large he
said should bear the cost of investment
in themselves and receive the rewards
although he noted of course that it's
extremely difficult to draw a sharp line
between these two types of education
Freeman rika regarded it as unjust for
taxpayers to fund a private benefit and
only appropriate for governments to make
taxpayers fund the type of education
whose benefits would accrue to society
at large since purely vocational
education increases the economic
productivity of the student but does not
trade him for either citizenship nor
leadership as did the American founders
Friedman regarded the chief purpose of
public elementary education to inculcate
common knowledge and morality like the
founders he did not deny that a liberal
education for a free people would have
salutary economic benefits but those are
of secondary and private concern in
setting this hierarchy he saw economics
as the handmaiden to a free society not
its master reversing the importance of
these two priorities gives us what we
have today incoherent technocratic
monopolized human capital Mills that
produce neither capable workers nor
self-governing human citizens because
they transgress human nature
Hillsdale professor Thomas West gives a
more a more robust account of the
founders view of the purpose of American
public education in his latest book
which I encourage you all to read
immediately in the founders view public
education was to promote three of the
four kinds of moral law religion
knowledge of the law of nature and
formation of moral
piñon government promotes knowledge of
the natural law by instruction in the
rational arguments that support it it
promotes obedience to the natural law by
putting students together in classrooms
where the law of fashion will exert its
power over them and by promoting a
belief in a God whose command support
that same law of nature West quotes
Thomas Jefferson's view of the duty of
public education to enable every citizen
to improve by reading his morals and
faculties and understand his duties to
his neighbors and country and know his
rights
today of course American public schools
can be largely said to actively
undermine all these things these
fundamental concerns America's own
founders believed were crucial to the
system of self-government they designed
yet they are utterly absent from common
core that's because common core
represents a vision for public education
at odds with human nature and the basic
economic principles derived from it
these include among others and I learned
these in dr. Wolfram's class that
parents have a duty and a right to lead
their children's formation that one's
actually mine but next are his that
centralizing power inevitably leads to
tyranny and high prices shortages and
low quality that government is
illegitimate if it does not operate upon
the consent of the governed that a
centralized bureaucracy driven system is
subject to regulatory capture and thus
will be driven by special interests or
what the founders called factions and
that setting people free to pursue their
own interests rightly understood and
freely associate with others organically
produces the best solutions to social
problems thanks to what Adam Smith
described as the invisible hand that
guides voluntary cooperation common core
violates all of these principles of
human nature and thus has been nothing
but disastrous for Americans take for
example just a few problems with central
planning manifest in the common core
project ever since US public schools
were required to establish centralized
curriculum mandates and tests under
President Clinton's goals 2000 and
subsequent federal law they have been
doomed to prescribe what serious
researchers have long known is
ineffective curricula because effective
curriculum
rich in core content good curricula
transcends narrow technical skills to
reach into the natural law centered
knowledge and habits America's founders
considered education x'
reason d'etre yet central planners
cannot prescribe specific content to
children first because the progressive
theories that have ruled u.s. public
education for a century insist against
the evidence that this is antiquated and
inappropriate and second because
specifying content inspires curriculum
wars that bogged down central planners
schemes these wars are generally between
those who support a core curriculum
liberal arts approach and those who
oppose it on the grounds that it is
racist sexist homophobic harmful to
child development hegemonic and so forth
so in an attempt to maintain neutrality
instead of inciting culture war mobs to
tar and feather them politicians and
bureaucrats avoid discussing the
foundational purposes and the content of
Education in the meantime the monopoly
structure of us education has allowed
leftist ideologues to gradually insert
their own politics into this blank space
by capturing its positions of power this
phenomena is jann known as regulatory
capture economists show that it leads to
cronyism high cost low quality in
general stagnation all of these are
clearly and indisputably apparent with
the United States education edges a
system and have been for decades yet the
economic analysis can only explain what
Herms happens in terms of financial
waste the effects on culture and society
more broadly are far worse not only does
it create political but also ideological
monopolies that come to exploit those
they should serve this dynamic is part
of the cold civil war that all Americans
wittingly or unwittingly are party to
that's a phrase that Claremont Institute
senior fellow Angelo ko Davila coined
this spring to describe the distinction
difference even M natee that has grown
exponentially over the past quarter
century between America's ruling class
and the rest of the country American
society has divided among along on
reconcilable visions of the good held by
country men who increasingly regard each
other
as enemies Kota Villa says because we
Americans irreconcilably disagree on the
aims of both private and public life
Americans disagree about what children
should learn in school and the potential
to compromise is basically zero between
reading and accurate biography of Thomas
Jefferson versus entirely invalidating
his contributions to the world because
he owned slaves
thus Common Core could not accomplish
its goal of nationalizing u.s. curricula
if it specified very much for children
to learn every single child might learn
is increasingly politically weaponized
at the hands of the captured regulators
at odds with America's silent majority
on the meaning of America many educators
believe are not taught to believe
ludicrously harmful things such as that
teachers should not teach arithmetic in
the most effective ways because minority
children cannot think abstractly this is
literal this is literally something that
are is taught to some teachers in New
York instead they say teachers should
use math class to subvert power and
question normalcy to avoid inciting
parents who think these sorts of things
are crazy and to see their awful results
common course creators had to provide
education mandates and tests that were
doomed to waste kids and teachers time
because content like curricula mandates
do not increase student learning their
alternative was dropping the project yet
they and the Obama administration that
put federal force behind Common Core
chose the former thus Common Core is not
so much an education and initiative as a
political initiative its true function
has been to further centralize power
away from parents teachers and citizens
to benefit America's ruling class at the
expense of the American people who fund
their comfortable lives the economic and
cultural aspects of this problem are but
different sides of a sword aimed at
dividing America from its own character
allowing centralized bureaucracies to
run public education amidst astha size
for decades has provided well-funded
safe spaces for those who hate American
ideals to feed special interest groups
upon the tax dollars of the Americans
they aim to subvert neutralized immoral
and convert the economic aspects at play
here are both manifest and contribute to
the deeper spiritual and cultural
problems that permeate American life
common core is not only locally
inadequate as a guide to substantive
learning both academically and morally
and conception and structure it is
deeply antithetical to the American
experiment it denies Americans
birthright to self-government and rule
by consent of the governed for just one
example of this and only four states the
common core ever passed through the full
legislature and nearly all of them after
every state had already committed to
common core through extra legal
agreements signed with the federal
government Common Core became the ruling
regime of American education almost
entirely through private agreements
among unelected government and private
nonprofit officials circumventing
elected officials was a deliberate
strategy and it worked three to four
years after the fact citizens heard what
had been done in their names to their
kids with their tax dollars and brought
their concerns to the people nominally
called their representatives by then
however Common Core was already moving
into classrooms and that foothold plus
the representatives cowardice made it
irreversible although most states have
renamed it and some have deceptively fed
Common Core through a thesaurus nearly
every state retains its substance
including Indiana the state in which I
live now politico's just lie to the
citizens by whose goodwill and tax
dollars they subsist not surprisingly
that goodwill has receded deeply public
trust in US institutions is at record
lows particularly in government
institutions and this sort of behavior
is a major isn't reason why the common
core regime is an insult to Americans
intelligence and rights but Arrangements
like it are endemic to American life
that's because again for decades a
ruling class has waged a cold war on the
American social compact they do not
agree with our founding Creed which says
the consent of the governed legitimizes
government for the sole purpose of
protecting our natural rights they
believe consent is negligible and
subject to manipulation they believe
humans have no fixed nature they believe
citizens serve the state not the other
way around
the epitome of their belief system is
the administrative state which by its
very nature violates American social
compact this administrative state is
encapsulated in common core like all the
other progressive education fads and
structures before it Common Core will
fade as its failure becomes increasingly
evident escape goaded on parents and
teachers then is used to justify yet
another step towards unlimited
government what will remain
conspicuously absent is a primary
concern for cultivating citizens
prepared to step into the duties
attendant to their natural rights
citizens like this after all would
refuse to subject American children to a
regime like common core
[Applause]
well you can see why she got an A in my
class our next speaker is Paul Peterson
he's the Henry Lee Shattuck professor of
government in the Department of
Government at Harvard University he
directs the Harvard program in education
policy and governance he's a senior
fellow at the Hoover Institute at
Stanford and a senior editor education
next which is an excellent publication I
don't know if you folks have had a
chance to look at it they receive his
PhD in political science at the
University of Chicago when he reforms me
that Milton Friedman was was there at
the time he's a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and the
National Academy of Education he's the
author or editor of over 30 books four
of which have been identified as the
best work in their field by the American
Political Science Association please
help me in welcoming Paul Peterson
[Applause]
good morning hmm I'll excuse my throat I
think it'll hold out but you know we're
grieving in Boston those Astros very
very this you know but you got to do one
thing it was the one thing that you can
do for us beat those Yankees yeah so I
direct the program on education policy
and governance at Harvard and so we
decided to hold a conference on the
title the future of school choice so I
thought well let's invite Betsy DeVos US
Secretary of Education to come and speak
to our conference and to speak more
generally to the students at Harvard and
that seemed to be this idea came to us
about last spring and through the summer
we worked very closely with the people
in Washington trying to persuade them
that this was a good use of the
Secretary's time and finally during the
fall we managed to close the deal and
she agreed to come and well a lot of
other people showed up too we had huge
demonstrations it sort of really started
in the law school because the Harvard
Law School is where this idea that you
should treat sexual harassment cases on
campus in ways that are different from
other crimes and they're in the
protection of the rights of the accused
don't apply and in this case in the same
way
so that's he the boss well that idea was
implemented by the Obama administration
and then she withdrew them which made
her unpopular in in certain circles on
the campus and then that combined with
the power of the teachers union in the
Boston area mobilized the thousands of
people to march around in
to create a lot of noise so yeah so I
I've had some interesting experiences in
the last couple of weeks but today we
want to talk about education because as
the panel before this one pointed out in
the 21st century we have to have an
educated population if we're going to
survive the globalization of the world
economy I didn't hear any disagreement
among the panelists despite different
points of view as to how we should
respond to globalization I didn't hear
anybody disagree with the idea that we
must have a better educated population
than we have today
and we haven't made the advances in
terms of enhancing our human capital
that really is is necessary so that's
going to be the background to what I
have to say today because one of the
most powerful ideas out there for
improving human capital in the United
States is school choice and I've got two
major takeaways in this conversation one
is that we are experimenting with school
choice through charter schools than
they've had a significant impact over
the past 20 years but their future is at
risk and the second point I'm going to
make is that the original idea that
Milton Friedman developed the idea of
vouchers has had much less impact but it
might have further impact in the future
as this idea has been transformed into
the concept of tax credits so let's
begin with the first question and that
is charter schools what are they like
how substantial are they I thought you'd
find it interesting just to learn what
is the distribution of students across
different kinds of schools in the United
States about 75% of the students in the
United States go to the school that's
assigned to them by their local school
district another 10% are attending
privates
that's down substantially from where it
once was when John Kennedy was president
it was more like 16 or 17 percent so
this is a shrinking sector of our
educational system the charter schools
have grown to about six percent and then
there are in schools that are run by
school districts but you have some
choice as to which school you go to
there's about 9% of what we call chosen
district schools so I'll talk about that
a little bit later
well the charter schools are still just
a small segment of the total there are
only six percent but they have shown
steady growth since 2000 and they
they're very small in the latter part of
the 20th century but beginning with the
21st century there's been a steady
growth in this sector of the economy
this sector of the education economy and
the charter schools remember our public
schools in the sense that they receive
public funding and they're authorized by
a government agency they're not like a
private school they're distinct from a
private school in that they receive
money from the government and they are
always subject to government regulation
and the government can shut them down on
the other hand they're like a private
school because they are operated by a
non-profit they're not subject to the
same kinds of regulations that other
public schools are in the United States
and they seldom have collective
bargaining they don't have to deal with
teacher unions in the same way that many
school districts do so one of the myths
about charter schools is that they serve
the well-to-do not true they serve the
disadvantaged when you look at this
chart the charter schools are the yellow
line and the purple is a line refers to
the private sector the Green Line is the
district schools and when you look at
those who
less education they are more likely to
be in charter schools than those who
have more education and the same is true
for those with more income I'm sorry the
blue is the is the private schools that
didn't come up initially so private
schools indeed do serve those with money
and with more education they that's
that's you have to pay for it but
charter schools do not they serve the
disadvantaged in terms of income and
family education and they serve a
minority population the Hispanic
population is more likely to go to
charter schools than to to district
schools their share of the of their I
didn't say that quite rightly their
share of the population is greater than
you would expect in the Charter sector
given its size for both African
Americans and Hispanics and the share in
the private sector is less as is true
for the district sector so and the in
the area of growth right now is in the
West we're seeing more charter schools
in the West than elsewhere also we see
more growth in the south and elsewhere
so a lot of the controversy is in the
East but a lot of the growth is in the
West well we did a survey last year that
looked at do parents like these charter
schools and do they like private schools
and do they like their district schools
and private schools win hands-down
that's the purple bar in this graph
people who send their kids to private
schools are much more satisfied with
teacher quality with school discipline
with academic expectations with safety
with character instruction by a large
margin
if you want to send your child to a
school where you are going to be
satisfied with what is being offered
there you need to send you need to pay
for your child's education and send them
to a private school we no question about
that but it's also the case that the
charter schools do a lot better than the
district schools in this respect so
they're sort of halfway between a
private school and a public school as
you would expect given the way they're
organized and then if you look at what's
the behavior of students at the school
as reported by the parents is the
problem of damaging property or missing
classes or fighting or using drugs is
this a serious problem well the green
bar is the district schools and yes a
lot of parents say all of these problems
are a significant problem in the
district run sector and not much of a
problem at all in the private sector big
differences between the green bar and
the purple bar big differences and once
again the charter schools fall somewhere
in between so how about going on to
college
what do charter schools help you go on
are they better at getting students
educated so they can go on to college
and so a very good study has been done
in Massachusetts which is called a
random assignment study so we can
compare kids who win the lottery and
lose the lottery and see does winning
the lottery make any difference and
that's a really good way to find out
whether or not schools make a difference
now this graph is all kinds of
statistics here so I'll just summarize
it by saying absolutely you're more
likely to go to college you're more
likely to graduate from college if you
go to a charter school in Massachusetts
if it's in Boston if it's in Boston if
they're more successful if it's not in
Boston if it's outlying
in other parts of the state charter
schools don't show up so well so why is
that that's a very curious thing the
charter schools seem to do better for
the disadvantaged kids than it does for
more advantage because kids coming from
higher income homes or better educated
families so the best we can figure it
out is that the charter schools that
serve the disadvantaged are the kind of
charter schools that are known as the no
excuses
schools they're the kind of schools that
really joy was talking about schools
where the expectations are very
rigorously defined and you're expected
to learn something in school and there's
a very clear program you wear uniforms
you sit up straight you emphases on
character development all of that is a
really important part of the
understanding of what the school is
trying to achieve it's almost a
throwback to the 19th century and these
schools seem to be working in our
Central City those in the other upstate
are more of the progressive variety
they're set up a charter schools can be
set up any way they want to be if they
can get a state authorizer
and in the areas that are more middle
class communities the charter schools
have a much more progressive let the
kids learn on their own let them figure
out what they want to do teachers should
be more laid-back all of that is is try
it out in charter schools do less well
so then if you look at studies around
the country you find this same pattern
you find that they disadvantage other
schools that the students are
disadvantaged they do better if they
come from more advantaged homes they do
not do well so the total impact of
charter schools in terms of academic
achievement is MIT is there's not you
can't just sort of say hurrah for
charters is a more mixed nuanced story
out there but that's not my main concern
my main concern is that this innovation
that's occurring in our country may be
coming to a halt or the expansion may be
slowing down and may be halted in the
not-too-distant future and the first
sign of it is the rate of growth has
begun the decline is is shown in this in
this graph the the number of useful
schools that are opening up every year
his has declined substantially just in
the last four years this is a very
recent development I wouldn't have said
this two years ago because I wouldn't
have seen a steady trend line over a
period of time and I think the main
reason is the power of the Union that
same group of people that were important
at the
that took place at Harvard not very long
ago that's it's not just there it's it's
a nationwide phenomenon the power of the
Union is being focused on charter
schools and the power of the Union is
evident from the fact that they can
raise money really easily by asking
every teacher to contribute to the Union
if as a condition of employment it's
deducted from their paycheck this isn't
done in every state but it's done in a
lot of states and as a result the
American Federation of Teachers and the
National Education Association ranked
number 10 and number 12 among all
organizations in the country that
contributed to political activity in the
last election and in the 2016 election
year according to the Center for
Responsive Politics so the Ease are the
most two of the three largest
organizations that have a union
connection our education organizations
that the union movement in the United
States is the teachers union movement
they are the most powerful union out
there they and that's because they have
lots of resources besides money
they've got workers on the ground at
every school district in the country in
every community in the country and they
and these people are educated themselves
they can speak they can write letters
they can mobilize this is a very
powerful force most unions represent
people in the trades people who don't
have that same set of skills that are so
used for for political action the
teachers union is a very powerful
organization and they have mobilized
against charter schools now why are they
doing that I think there are three
events that have led to this
transformation in union strategy
recently and the first one has to do
with a de bankruptcy in Detroit somebody
mentioned Detroit Public Schools well
what really happened in Detroit was the
message came through that when you have
very large pensions going to government
employees it can
the whole system down and the district
schools in big cities could be brought
down by the rising pension Oh aye this
graph didn't come up on the screen I'm
sorry about that because this graph was
a really interesting graph that tells us
that the twenty twenty percent of a
teacher's salary is now going a total
compensation package is now going for
pensions in the United States as
compared to ten percent ten years ago
twelve years ago from two thousand four
two thousand seventeen ten percent to 20
percent and so the cost per pupil of the
pension system had doubled now this even
greater than that in big cities in big
cities just double those numbers so in
big cities big city school districts are
raising revenue to pay for the legacy
costs because the pension programs
weren't adequately funded in the past
and the healthcare system is on top of
that and that's there's equally large
problem so when you have that problem
you've got to maintain your enrollments
in your district schools or you're going
to be marching towards bankruptcy that
was the story that comes from Detroit
and that's the story that Philadelphia
faces and Baltimore faces and Chicago
faces and lots of other cities around
the country are facing so when students
and families exercise their right of
choice to go to a charter school they
are adding to this problem it's not a
problem that the charter school is
created is the problem that the district
school is created for themselves by
creating a system as that's marching off
to bankruptcy but the slogan that's out
there now that the union movement is
making so successfully is that charters
take money away from the public schools
they used to say charter schools aren't
any good or charter schools serve the
rich or charter schools don't have
enough special education students then
those arguments cut any ice but the new
argument is cutting ice as saying
they're taking money away from this
public schools and the reason why that's
such a powerful argument is because the
bankruptcy problem is facing our
district
schools so let me go back one in Chicago
we got a new union leader who comes to
power Karen Lewis and she takes on Mayor
Rahm Emmanuel calls a strike brings the
city to a halt the next time around the
Emmanuel has to give in too he can't
stand another strike and one of the
conditions that he has to agree to is no
more charter schools in Chicago so
that's one of the phenomenon that's out
there is that collective bargaining is a
new phenomenon it's part of the
collective bargaining process the unions
are demanding no more charters so
they're not being able to pull it off
everywhere but increasingly so this is
on their table this is one of their top
objectives so the third event is the
departure of Arne Duncan who was the
superintendent in Chicago did a lot of
great things in Chicago before he went
off to Washington to serve in the Obama
administration and he did a lot of
things to try to promote the charter
school movement around the country it's
not really fully appreciated and once he
left and there was no longer a
Democratic Party support for the concept
of charters it's sort of unleashed the
unions and so the unions have had an
impact and it's had an impact in part
because the efforts by the federal
government to fix the schools during the
Bush administration's and the Obama
administration's really didn't have the
impact that was expected of them as joi
was discussing all the accountability
systems that were put into place did not
enhance reading in the in the US schools
now reading scores in the United States
are still at the age 15 are still a
little bit higher than the OECD average
that's the average for all
industrialized countries in the world
just slightly above that but they have
been falling at a fast
rate than in other countries and the
math scores which have always trailed
those in other countries are just
plunging I mean there was happened
between 2008 and 2015 and the math
sector is just dramatic and it's never
been discussed in the mainstream press
that over the last 10 years we've seen a
collapse and the ability of our teachers
to teach math to students that they by
the age of 15 so but the Obama
administration's a failure to improve
the educational system and its departure
from the scene has unleashed the left
wing of the Democratic Party whether
you're talking about Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren or the N double AC P or
the mainstream press all of them have
joined in the movement against charter
schools as can be shown here by this
Washington Post I just took these things
out of Google the top 10 stories every
single one of these stories in the
Washington Post as an anti charter story
and if you look at the headlines around
the country that's what you're getting
okay so the result of that is a decline
in support for charters for the first
time for a long time our polling we do
polling every year has shown steady
support for charters among the general
public that's the yellow bar there but
in 2017 the last year we saw a major
drop from 51% in 39% in favor of
charters and the corresponding increase
in opposition to charters that's the
dotted line it's true among Republicans
and Democrats alike so that's that's the
impact that this effort by the unions
has had on the general public now my
time is run out so I'm gonna have to
lead my full discussion of school
vouchers and tax credits to any
questions you might have but the main
point I want to bring out there the
takeaway point is the bounty program has
only had an impact
of 1% or less than 1% of students are
making use of vouchers these programs
have not been institutionalized but the
tax credit idea is gaining support in
Illinois they just passed a bill amazing
that this was passed in Illinois and
it's been passed in a number of other
states and the tax credit program which
has lots of flexibility gives the
private sector a lot more choice in the
school is proving very popular among
private school administrators among poor
families and has got an institutional
design that allows for the political
mobilization of parents and families
around keeping the program intact and is
less capable of being attacked on
constitutional grounds they're very hard
to say that a tax credit is
unconstitutional since it's been widely
used for all kinds of purposes so to sum
up more could be said on this subject
but to sum up we have a changing we're
at a at a at a pivoting point when it
comes to school choice in the United
States we've seen this steady growth on
the part of charters for a sustained
period of time with some signs that it
could really transform the system by
making breakthroughs in various parts of
the country with as many as half the
kids in Washington DC going to a charter
school and with all of the kids in New
Orleans going to a charter school and
30% going to a charter school in Detroit
and Philadelphia we're on the verge of a
breakthrough but the opposition has
recognized that and is mobilizing in
force and so the way forward is going to
be much more complicated than the road
that we have traveled thus far thank you
[Applause]
well now the next topic of a federal
federal policy in higher education and
David Randall is director of
communications at the National
Association of scholars two very fine
organizations some of you may be members
while at the NA su is written on civics
education making citizens how American
universities teach civics college common
readings Beach books
what do colleges and universities want
students to read outside class and the
College Board's Advanced Placement
European history exam the disappearing
continent a critique of the revised AP
European history examination here's also
co-author of a forthcoming work on
reproducibility crisis in science modern
science the crisis of reproducibility
dr. Randall received his PhD in history
from Rutgers in 2005 so he's just a
child
his academic publications include
credibility in Elizabethan and early
Stuart military news English military
news pamphlets 1513 1637 Adam Smith's
mixed prudence and economy of the public
sphere the rhetoric of violence the
public sphere and the Second Amendment
and the concept of conversation and I
had to ask him how you do the French
part of this maybe he'll make make me
look good by saying that's how it was
from Cicero's sir--no to the gracias
gracias ley conversation that close
enough which is forthcoming in 2018 he's
also published essays interestingly on
the speculative fiction and folk music
at first things and is the author of
young adult fantasy series in the shadow
of the bear he was born in Manhattan and
now lives in Brooklyn with his wife and
son please help me bring in David
Randall
I'd like to thank Hillsdale for inviting
me thank you very much I'd also like to
say this is my first time in Texas it's
lovely to be here and I hope it won't be
my last
so the United States Department of
Education just improved college
education for millions of students it
withdrew one of its edicts last month
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
rescinded the department's Dear
Colleague letter of 2011 for six years
this letter arbitrarily imposed by
assistant secretary Russel and Ally of
the department's Office for Civil Rights
guided colleges to use legal processes
and evidentiary standards that abrogated
due process protections for students
accused of sexual assault any college
that didn't obey face the prospect of
losing its eligibility to receive
federal money colleges around the
country soon complied by creating
bureaucracies to draft and execute
policies to abrogate their students
civil liberties these new policies
naturally set off a brushfire of
lawsuits against the universities and by
the end of 2016
students had a triumph in the courtroom
in cases filed against institutions
including the University of Southern
California the University of Tennessee
at Chattanooga and George Mason
University the federal government
created a new norm in American higher
education petty tyranny tempered by
lawsuit rescinding the Dear Colleague
letter doesn't undo all its damage
colleges that responded to the Dear
Colleague letter by entering into
voluntary resolution agreements such as
Yale University must still follow those
agreements guidelines hundreds of star
chamber bureaucracies within each
individual university remain
and now work voluntarily to infringe
student Liberty the Department of
Education impaired Liberty on campus
with alarming ease it is far more
difficult for it to restore Liberty and
even the good it is doing now can be
undone by another Secretary of Education
with a stroke of the pen at the National
Association of scholars
my colleagues and I conduct research
into a wide range of federal policies
toward higher education from
sustainability initiatives to civic
education the story of the Dear
Colleague letter is the story everywhere
the federal government does harm easily
and limited good only with great effort
while Americans can sometimes marshal
policy federal policy to improve higher
education federal power itself poses a
constant danger to good education to
cheap education and to the very Liberty
of Americans the taproot of that power
is the flow of federal money to
individual colleges and universities
above all via loans and grants to
subsidize student tuition but also
through a host of other dedicated grant
programs the federal government directs
more than eighty billion dollars
annually to higher education via grants
and income tax rebates and it also
guarantees higher education loans more
than a hundred billion dollars of
student loans each year four-fifths of
first year college students receive a
grant or a loan from the federal
government and American colleges derive
more than one third of their revenues
from the federal government virtually
every College in the country save
Hillsdale
both depends on and abuses the stream of
money from the federal government
colleges abuse the system by diverting
as much as possible of each federal
dollar to benefit themselves a 2015
study by the federal Federal Reserve
Bank of New York concluded the colleges
raised tuition by 60 cents for each
dollar they receive in federal direct
subsidized loans university
administrators compound the abuse by
using this money to hire administrators
rather than faculty in the last 30 years
the ratio of administrators to teachers
has more than doubled the same subsidy
leads colleges to sacrifice an ever
larger amount of autonomy to supervising
bureaucracies both within the Department
of Education itself and within the
nonprofit accrediting agencies that work
in tandem with the federal government
government regulations and putative Lea
independent accreditation standards work
together to standardize colleges who all
jump through the same bureaucratic hoops
so as to preserve their funding
eligibility and create near identical
bureaucracies within each College tasked
to remake their institution Harvard
University alone employs more than 50
title 9 coordinators the price colleges
pay for their mess of government pottage
is homogeneity and submission the
government billfold ensures obedience to
the government web Americans will not
reestablish colleges freedom from the
federal government or Liberty for
college students until they cut the
taproot of government money our
representatives should eliminate
student grants and loans entirely so as
to remove the leverage they provide the
Department of Education what remains of
the Department of Education x' office of
post-secondary education should focus
upon information gathering and publicity
this goal will not be achieved until the
still distant day when Americans believe
that they can dispense with federal
education subsidies in the interim we
must work to reform how the government
exercises its power to shape higher
education our dual goal should be to
limit the ability of the government to
do harm by its education policy and to
foster higher education contribution to
our country's welfare specifically
federal policy toward higher education
should aim at five complementary goals
first it should restore autonomy to
institutions of higher education by
restricting the government's power to
regulate individual colleges second it
should restore individual liberty within
our college campuses third it should
ensure that higher education continues
to dedicate itself to the interests and
the welfare of our nation fourth it
should endeavour to reduce the cost of
college fifth and last it should remove
those federal regulations that impose
progressive dogma in the name of
education
[Applause]
the most powerful means we have to
restore autonomy to our colleges is to
eliminate the Department of Education
office for civil rights the OCR which
takes its power to prevent
discrimination as license to force
college administration's to engage in
legal witch hunts the most important
phrase in OCR is 2014 supplement to the
Dear Colleague letter was that quote a
title 9 investigation is not
discretionary unquote to free our
colleges from the OCR's demand that they
function as auxiliary police rather than
educators Congress should transfer all
legal functions currently entrusted to
the office for civil rights to the
Justice Department College autonomy will
only flourish when colleges are freed
from a bureaucracy committed to their
subordination we must also restore
Liberty to individual students and
faculty members the Liberty to study in
an environment free of disruption and
intimidation the Liberty to hear varied
opinions the Liberty to speak free of
intimidation threats of reprisals or
actual violence the Liberty to proclaim
one's faith and the Liberty to associate
freely in student organizations that
determine their own requirements for
membership and qualifications for
leadership students and faculty accused
of misdeeds must also have the legal
rights that are our birthright as
Americans due process the presumption of
innocence the right to counsel the right
to know what one is charged with the
right to face one's accuser and the
right at all times to speak publicly
about any case the different branches of
the federal government should work
together to guarantee these liberties
secretary de Vos began this work by
rescinding the Dear Colleague letter
Attorney General sessions has followed
up with his announcement that the
Justice Department will now protect
student rights to speak speak freely
both departments should continue the
good work of enforcing existing federal
laws and regulations in defense of
individual liberty on campus yet and
there is a yet a new administration can
reverse these initiatives Congress
should provide a permanent guarantee for
student liberties by amending the Higher
Education Act to include the freedom to
learn amendments drafted by the National
Association of scholars these require
colleges that receive federal student
loans to guarantee individual student
liberties and due process rights and
appoint an independent commission to
assess compliance Congress should also
set up its own legal office tasks to
review all Department of Education
guidance letters to determine whether
they misinterpret the department's
statutory powers so as to restrict
individual Liberty on campus federal
higher education policy should combine
these efforts to foster institutional
and individual liberty with
complementary initiatives to ensure that
America's colleges dedicate themselves
to our nation's welfare American
universities should foster American
interests serve the American people
preserve their independence from the
soft power of foreign governments and
instill a shared identity as Americans
among their students the government
should take measured steps to encourage
American colleges to rededicate
themselves to these national purpose
and ideals many universities have become
instruments of foreign soft power china
now funds more than 100 Confucius
Institutes on American campuses which
teach Chinese language culture and
history and never mentioned topics such
as the massacre at Tiananmen Square
these Institute's staffed by Chinese
nationals subject to Chinese law a
dictum erican universities - Chinese
government funding and thereby the
Institute's acquire a veto on University
policy in 2009 North Carolina State
University withdrew an invitation to the
Dalai Lama to speak on campus reportedly
after the director of the campus
Confucius Institute objected Congress
should require all colleges that receive
federal funds to disclose all funding
from foreign governments and all
contractual language governing their
foreign funded components the federal
government should also require that
colleges treat all American citizens
alike and distinguish American citizens
from non-citizens in the long run the
federal government should rescind all
affirmative action and diversity
mandates from higher education as these
treat American citizens unequally in the
short run Congress should require all
colleges that accept federal support to
provide full institutional transparency
about the demographic characteristics of
their student body so as to make clear
to the public the discriminatory effects
of affirmative action Congress should
also amend the Higher Education Act to
require colleges to cooperate with the
enforcement of America's immigration
laws sanctuary colleges such as the
University of Pennsylvania should
receive no
federal money
[Applause]
federal policy toward higher education
should foster liberty and the common
welfare of Americans and it should also
work to make college as cheap as
possible for Americans this should be
done both for the direct good it will do
to the pocketbook of millions of us and
to convince Americans that government
does not need to subsidize higher
education the federal government can
lower college costs most effectively by
exposing the existing cartel of higher
education to competition from new rivals
by providing a regulatory infrastructure
that favors as many educational
experiments as possible these
experiments should include virtually all
currently proposed alternatives to
traditional forms of higher education
the Department of Education should
continue its efforts to lift the unequal
regulatory burden they places on
for-profit colleges if the federal
government wants for-profit colleges to
provide statistics about gainful
employment of their graduates it should
require the same information from
community colleges and the Ivy League
the department should also encourage
attempts to provide distance learning
over the Internet
while Congress should authorize income
share agreements student loans tied to
repayment of a proportion of students
future income rather than repayment of a
fixed stop the more room the federal
government provides for competing
institutions and financial structures
the more quickly
Americans will discover a way to make
college cheaper federal policy and
higher education should aim positively
to promote Liberty and American welfare
and to lower the cost of college
it should also aim to prune away a
jumble of programs that function as
subsidies for progressive propogate
and activism these programs are wasteful
an improper diversion of government
money toward political ends and a
subsidy of the cadres in higher
education devoted to arbitrary
government and disdain for America both
the cause of liberty and the common
welfare of America require that the
federal government defund these
subsidies for the authoritarian left the
most pernicious of these subsidies
supports a constellation of activities
that include civic engagement civic
learning service-learning and global
civics these programs all substitute
extracurricular action for classroom
learning and usually action to spread
progressive propaganda or to provide
free labor for progressive nonprofit
organizations and teach students that
civics education is the same thing as
progressive activism the Department of
Education provides massive regulatory
support for this program of putatively
civic education 7% of work-study funds
awarded to each College must be used for
community service positions and so
Cornell College in Iowa uses federal
work-study funds to pay a social justice
program campus coordinator the
Department of Education should rescind
its regulations fostering civic
engagement Congress should also amend
the Higher Education Act so that no
service learning class is eligible for
government financial aid all these
reforms make up a large program
indeed I am under no illusions that it
can be achieved in four years or even
eight but we should know what we aim for
even if we know that we cannot achieve
all our goals
at once the federal government will do
great good if it enacts even a small
part of these reforms and each small
reform can build toward a larger
transformation of higher education
secretary DeVos and attorney journal
attorney General Sessions have begun
very well and much more can be done yet
the federal government has limited power
to undo the entrenched cultural and
administrative power of authoritarian
leftism in higher education government
cannot compel academics to love Liberty
so fixing a federal policy toward higher
education can only be the beginning of a
solution we must work to cure higher
education in our other offices as
students teachers and administrators as
alumni and as parents and above all as
citizens who call on the institutions of
higher education to teach the ideals of
liberty and promote the interests of
America we should expect our colleges to
be Scots schools of Liberty students
should be taught to expect the right to
speak speak freely to encourage the same
freedom in their fellow students and to
expect their colleges unequivocally to
defend all student liberty students
should learn never to subordinate
liberty to euphemisms for arbitrary
government and mob rule social justice
diversity and other false idols we
should expect our colleges to be schools
devoted to the welfare of America and
the welfare of Americans students should
learn to love their country and their
fellow citizens our colleges should
teach them the history of their country
so that they may cherish America with
both their minds and their hearts and
know how to sustain the Republican form
of government that guarantees our
liberties
we Americans and not just our servants
in the federal government must labor so
that our educators rally our colleges
and universities to cherish liberty and
the common good of our country we may
use the federal government as one tool
in that effort but we cannot rely upon
it the task is ours
well another fine panel we do have time
for questions but please remember that
to wait for the microphone to be given
to you because this program is being
recorded so like and you can address
your question to individuals on the
panel or to the panel as a whole yes I'd
like to address the panel as a whole
about you know 10 to 6 years ago when I
was still in high school something I
noticed is that to just about everybody
there regardless of our regardless to
our academic background or or what are
you know what our standardized test
scores were anything like that there was
always the stress on Strictly College
and understand that at the time in a
span of 10 to 6 years ago that this was
when we had a we had very high
unemployment and there was no there was
no stress on getting to the addressing
the labor market in the trades and I
mean and this even goes so far as to
charter schools where I see a a
surprising gap of folks who come out of
you know come out of other you know
district schools or public schools or
charter schools and even and then even
private schools who don't exactly know
where they want to go even even though
they want to go or they want to go to
college but they don't exactly know like
how they would make a living afterwards
and I see that as a gap in the American
labor market and I'd like to know if
there's a way that any of you think that
that gap could be a Perot fixed or maybe
not fixed but alleviated by perhaps a
charter school system that would have
some sort of emphasis in trades or give
people that opportunity while they were
still in school that's are themselves
well I could take a crack at that most
Americans want to have their child's go
to a four-year college and most parents
of children under the age of 18 are even
more likely to want to have their child
go to a four-year college and it's true
that the difference between a four-year
degree and a two-year degree on average
is larger today than it ever has been in
the past and the reason for that is very
simple only an individual who's well
educated is going to be able to survive
in the economy of the 21st century the
globalized economy of the 21st century
we are going to see a decline in the
number of good-paying working jobs that
vocational jobs that vocational schools
have been focused on now that doesn't
mean they're going to disappear there's
always going to be a need for them and
there's certainly room for charter
schools or other schools to provide that
kind of educational opportunity for
those who want it but I don't see a
compelling need for a national policy to
push policymaking in that direction
those jobs are on the way out technology
is replacing those jobs so a four-year
degree is today more valuable than it
ever has been
I'm gonna disagree a little bit I
actually wanna wanna I think if any of
you have read Charles Murray's work he
talks about it's really destructive
socially as well as to the employment
prospects of young people to have this
meant a it is true that meant most
Americans many Americans expect their
children to go to four-year college but
that isn't that's just because they want
to see their children set up well in
life it's that the and and that pressure
of acting like a four-year college
degree is really a good fit towards
helping a young person to a career has
really destroyed a lot of young people's
lives you know saddled young people with
a lot of college debt for a degree they
don't know where it's going they you
know that it's kind of a generic well I
got my I checked my box and then if you
talk to college instructors I'm sure
David can talk about this all the time
you know if you talk to college
instructors they have many of these
students in the classrooms who don't
know why they're there who aren't
prepared to do the work because college
is more of an academic setting it's not
it's often not a vocational oriented
setting so it's a very poor match
between young people who just want to
you know get going on their lives so
I've I've done a lot of time you might
my dad is a small business owner he's a
farmer in Wisconsin we have friends who
own a manufacturing company in Ohio and
so those are the sort of jobs you know
that you're thinking about and they're
actually the age of the folks who are
doing plumbing the trades construction
electrical work is in the 50s and the
60s and they're having a really hard
time recruiting young people and those
are high-paying jobs that cannot be
outsourced if you need a plumber
you can't call up somebody in India to
do it for you it's in your sink in your
kitchen so I mean so there is definitely
a gap there that economists have talked
about and there are real opportunities
there you know they are and I think it's
more of a mentality thing as well as the
fact that the sort of people who talk
about what people should do after
college or people who have all gone to
college and like going to college but
you know as dr. Murray talks about all
the time not everybody likes reading
books and writing papers and that isn't
a good preparation for a good career
form even the majority of people so
there are many other avenues that they
they can have and I think you know
there's a lot of people are talking
about this as well you know there's
there's credentialing programs that big
engineering companies are starting up in
Indiana there's state-level programs in
the states where they have a workforce
that kind of is geared towards this
people are trying to think about it and
solve it for me I always think about so
when I talk to my dad or a manufacturing
plant owner friends what they say is as
actually its how do you say it there's
there's a couple of laws that are real
huge barrier and one of them is minimum
wage laws if it is another one of them
is you know laws that bar people from
starting work before age 16 17 18 you
know if you can get in work 1015 hours a
week at age 15 you know doing the easy
boring stuff by the time you're 18 you
can be you know an apprentice and by the
time you're 20 - I mean in our local our
local high school has kids you know
they're making starting level salaries
of $45,000 you know with the two-year
technical degree but you know because
they've been able to do that through
their high school so there are
definitely avenues that I don't think we
focused on because of our cultural
pressure towards putting everyone into
college but that really is hurting
people so I agree with you about the
need their own another thing I wanted to
mention besides the minimum wage the
restrictions on young work the inability
kind of break up the you know the
ability to kind of slowly move into as
an apprentice now into a job as a young
person I hear a lot of folks they can't
hire people who a have a work ethic and
B can pass a drug test so we have a lot
of social problems that are creating
these workforce gaps that everybody
always acts like just sending a
drug-addicted person to school is going
to be you know get them a credential
that's not really going to solve the
problem you know that we're talking
about with all these unemployed folks
who are in bad jobs that don't fit their
interests and aptitudes
gets to support that briefly in effect a
depressingly large amount of college
disguises a high real unemployment rate
and adds to that some minimal
remediation for the material you should
have learned in high school a great many
college graduates in effect are entering
jobs they should have been educated to
do at the age of 18 and simply start
that way there's then the question of
how do you reform education policy to
make things more sensible that's bigger
than we could do in the next few minutes
but college is a makeshift in many ways
not a solution
[Applause]
there's a big controversy over common
core but what I like at Hillsdale they
have a core of some 60 hours other
schools have virtually nothing so really
it seems like the real controversy is
who determines the core rather than what
the car is well if you read my book I
will go through that argument in more
detail I absolutely support a core
curriculum because I mean it's I have
learned that way it's a great way to
learn and the research says it's really
good for helping young people become
adults the problem is I actually think
it is a structural problem it's when we
talk about Common Core the fact that it
tries to be a national scheme is the
very reason that it has to be garbage
curriculum as you know I talked about
today trying to do anything national
requires getting enough buy-in from
enough people that you're going to have
to make so many compromises that the
thing that you do ends up not being
something worth the name you know of a
core of knowledge that is delivered to
children
all right next question yes I graduated
from the University of Texas at
Arlington 1987 my last semester I took
15 hours my tuition was $650 since that
you know the federal government has
gotten so deeply into giving the loans
and the money the prices are just
astronomical how do we get the federal
government out of the student loan and
business and and the rest of it that's
the difficulty one thing that we could
do is simply say that if you want a
federal loan or a Pell Grant which is a
grant to go to college if you're from a
low-income family you have to show that
your college ready you need to pass some
kind of an external examination you have
to have something more than just your
high school diploma on the table in
order to obtain that subsidy right now
about half the students who go to junior
colleges drop out before the end of the
first year we have a huge expansion of a
junior college community college system
in the United States that's been built
on the back of the Pell Grant program
and college loans and the most of the
people who aren't paying back their
loans are people who are going for one
year or not for that entire year for a
portion of that year and can't do the
work they're just not prepared for it we
can have a major cut in the subsidies to
a significant segment of our higher
educational system if we simply said
well you've got to perform at a certain
level before you're gonna be eligible
and think of what that would do to our
high schools I mean when you look at the
educational system in the United States
you have to say elementary schools could
be better but they're not broken you see
you see students improving over the
generations they're probably learning
more
elementary schools a day than they did
20 years ago middle school much less
satisfactory middle school is a problem
area high school disaster zone kids hate
it nobody wants to go to school nobody
knows why they're in school nobody knows
what they're supposed to study there is
no such thing as a core curriculum study
whatever you want
and so with there's no examination
system it used to be the teachers would
hold the students accountable but its
teachers are given up on that it gets
them into trouble and besides that
schools get money from the state based
on how many students they have and so
the big thing now is to get kids to
graduate from high school they're
supposed to be you you're supposed to
have a higher percentage of kids
graduating from high school every year
and that has happened that's that big
achievement of the Obama administration
is to increase high school graduation
rates how have they done that they've
allowed students if they fail a course
to take it online in a room separate
from the other and they can take it over
and over and over again until they pass
is it you know and they don't have to
pass that the expected level so they say
there are schemes out there in our
educational system that's making it
really easy to get a high school diploma
so so why should colleges say a high
school diploma is all it takes to get to
college well because they can make money
on you because they can get the federal
grants and they can get the loan based
funding so you could do something for
our high schools and for our college
problem simply by raising the
expectations for admission to college I
do want to say I think it will be a
[Applause]
sorry I didn't mean to cut that off on a
bigger pardon I want to say I think it
will be more difficult because any
reform you put in can and will be
subverted you know put in an expectation
level you make the expectation level
lower force colleges to get rid of you
say you're not allowed to let students
do remedial stuff they'll redefine the
remedial classes as the first year of
college and lower the expectations for
college it's going that sort of dodge
will happen and I think they'll be able
to get away with it for as long as tens
of millions of Americans are absolutely
terrified that their children will be
impoverished if they don't have the
federal government loans there's got to
be massive slow reforms which have to
acknowledge that sheer terror among so
many people that it's going it'll be
politically impossible to make any sort
of quick or direct assault it has to be
every sort of reform has to get you to
the situation where that terror
disappears and that's going to take a
generation or two at least we have time
for one more question
this is not really a question because I
wish you could answer it I'm a school
teacher took the day off 36 students in
a biology class yesterday 90% of them do
not speak English these students will
pass the biology standard Texas test so
that they can graduate everything is
being dumbed down in public education
I feel the frustration yesterday in a
first period did those students stand
for the Pledge no I spent all my time I
realized that this is off the subject
I'm really hot and frustrated and thank
you for allowing me to be here today
because maybe there is hope but those of
us who are in the southern states and
other states who are having the problem
with people in our schools who don't
even speak English and they won't be
conversant in English when they graduate
from high school and we will give
scholarships to those because they are
in the underserved quote unquote they
have don't have the means quote quote
and they represent diversity
you raise a point that's really
important to me as a mother because
basically education policy if we think
about it in economic terms we're really
limiting it because it's really family
policy so we think about children who
are having problems and we're we're
asking our schools to be their mothers
and their fathers and their social
workers and their counselors and their
doctors and everything else so when
people are dissatisfied you know with
what schools are putting out and look I
know based on the research that folks
like dr. Peterson have done that the
schools are not doing as well as they
could with the met you know with the
children that they have but there are so
many other things that we're also asking
our schools to do that we really never
want to talk about because it's really
easy to talk in economic terms about
human capital just getting people a
couple points high around a math test
you can regionals but how do you say how
do we have more mothers marrying fathers
before they have children
[Applause]
all right well I'd like to have you help
me thank this wonderful panel and then
you can go to life
[Applause]